- There is no debate.
I will continue to say
what I said a year ago
especially 'cause a lot
of you weren't here.
This is what actually works
creatively on the internet,
and the internet really matters.
- [Together] Hey!
- You've got more perspective.
(cheering)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(easy music with driving beat)
One of the best parts of being CEO
of this company in the last four months,
is way more one-on-one
meetings have happened,
and I can't tell you how much
as a macro that makes me feel better
'cause it's not only the hundred people
I've seen the last 120 days,
it's also the two to three
that they've affected by the meetings
I've had internally
and I think it's been collectively good
and I'd like to triple
down on more of that.
Hey everybody, um, was really
looking forward to this
so I'm excited to be here.
I just couldn't encourage
a more collaborative
culture of asking questions.
I'm trying to create the permission
for somebody who's on their first week
to reach out to the most senior creative
and ask her or him, you know,
hey, what was this about,
or how did you get there?
So I think that's how we take this meeting
and take it from a moment in time
and make it actually living and breathing
which is disproportionately
the most important thing
that we can accomplish as a company.
So please heed that.
Let's talk about VBM.
Volume model was very
important to me to establish
about a year ago for a lot of reasons,
but if you play all the chess moves
it's because when I hear that term
I don't think that that's
a thing in the way that I,
and we have positioned it.
I think it really means best in class
digital creative work
which unless you're
not living in the world
I'm sure you realize the internet is real
and the dynamics on that platform
continue to inform us in our thinking
and our behavior and I wanted,
and we continue need to
be the best in the world
as communicators on that platform.
From the horses mouth with no hyperbole,
or in my normal disproportionately
optimistic kind of DNA,
we are wildly ahead of pace
with volume model interject
in this company.
For us to be going from
a place of, you know,
11 months ago standing in front
of the company and saying,
here's this thing and
let there be no confusion
for the ones in here that
don't know me as well.
It was not well-received,
meaning mentally,
like everybody thought this is cute,
but I'm gonna do my own shit, right?
Or this is theoretical,
but this isn't real,
or most of all which is the
great mistake of companies,
my customer's not gonna like this.
You know we talk a lot about our job
as strategy creative account people
is to say the right things,
move our clients in the right place,
but the reality is it's a very tough job.
I have enormous empathy for account people
in their day-to-day interactions
where you're punched in the face verbally
by account, the clients
and things of that nature
and, you know, and so I am so excited
about how far along we are,
most of all internally.
To go from 90% of the
organization not being bought in
to 50 is a lot of
advancement in 11 months.
It just means half the company
still doesn't know what it is,
believe in it, or things of that nature,
which means we have a lot of work to do
because we have not shot with
the clients, or the world,
unless we internally understand.
There is no debate.
I will continue to say
what I said a year ago,
especially 'cause a lot
of you weren't here.
This is what actually works
creatively on the internet
and the internet really matters.
Love you guys.
(clapping)
(upbeat music)
That's the brilliance of
a volume-creative model.
The reason I'm smart and
have all these insights
is 'cause I've created a content machine
that led to me listening.
It looks like I'm talking, it
led to me listening, right?
- [Man] That's good.
- It is crazy, it's a good one.
I made sure Dustin caught it, you know.
(laughing)
All the talking has led
to a level of listening
that gives me such
profound consumer insights.
I will push everybody to podcasts
like you would no believe,
even more than video,
'cause I think videos a bigger mental
and infrastructural jump for many.
I love podcasts because of the following.
You do a podcast,
you film the podcast
which gives you video,
you get the guest's audience,
when they're a guest,
because they're gonna promote it
bringing you awareness.
The first person can be the
fucking third generational guy
who's 58 who owns the boat company in town
that's been crushing for years.
And when you email him on
LinkedIn, or his email,
and say, hey John, you
wanna be the first guest
on the BOCA Business
Podcast, the answer's, yes,
'cause John's not being asked by anybody
to be on a podcast, got it?
And then literally the
content's a piece of cake.
So John, tell us about
how you got started?
So John, what's happening now?
How's BOCA changed in the last, like,
you're fucking 40 minutes done
before you even started.
Asking four questions and going to sleep.
For the first eight years of my career
I didn't have a team.
So the way I would've done it is like,
I would've had my iPhone on
the table and recorded it
and then literally posted the
raw fucking video on LinkedIn.
So like, you know, people again,
being the messenger of a lot of these,
a lot of these things,
right out scares me,
because I have a level of
notoriety now, leverage,
infrastructure, but I got here
by doing what I'm telling you to do.
- That's really nice.
- Thank you bud, thank you.
You're welcome, thanks guys.
- All right folks welcome to
the G.R.I.T. Leadership Podcast
where we try and build
better leaders and teammates
through gratitude, relationships,
innovation and team work.
What is it that helps y'all
focus on that and, you know,
get back to center, or
find that gratitude,
you know, every day?
- I actually go with gratitude,
guilt, and scaring myself.
So I've been thinking a lot lately
about my mindset and like
today I came back to the office
after being away for two weeks
which is very unusual for me,
which means I had an enormous amount
of headaches on my plate.
And no matter how bad anything is
I always go to a place of well,
what if my mom got killed.
What if right now I got a phone call
from a hysterical sister saying,
mom's dead, she was murdered, right?
And for some reason I
do that 55 times a year.
Sometimes it's my mom,
sometimes it's my kids
and my wife driving and getting hit by,
but this unbelievable
ability to actually feel
enormous life-changing deep painful pain
that just in seconds puts everything
in such basic perspective
that I don't know,
there's nothing else.
You know what I love, by the way,
'cause I'm just bouncing.
(laughing)
You know what's awesome
about New York City?
(voice covers voice)
When I walk in New York City
this always runs through my mind.
It's a grid and I have 800,000,
like I always feel like I'm funny,
like I don't walk the same way ever.
Like if I have to go somewhere
I'm always doing different shit,
like going three avenues
and then two streets.
Like I don't know why it's probably
my entrepreneurial chaotic way
where as like my dad walks
the same way exact way every time.
And I, every time I do it,
if I run into a stranger,
a friend, or something,
I'm always like that's so cool,
it's so fucking cool that I
could've went one more avenue
and then took the, and
like, basically I think
we're completely not
in control of anything
which kind of weirdly makes me feel
in control of everything.
- That's right on.
(laughing)